♪ ♪
>> Mike: LET’S GET AN UPDATE
ON COVID RELIEF BILL
NEGOTIATIONS, MITCH McCONNELL
JOINS US AS EVENING.
ARE YOU CONFIDENT THERE WILL BE
A DEAL ON A COVID-19 RELIEF BILL
BY THE END OF THIS WEEK?
>> I SURE HOPE SO, THE
DISCUSSIONS CONTINUE.
I THINK BOTH SIDES WANT TO GET
TO AN OUTCOME, THAT’S THE GOOD
NEWS.
THE BAD NEWS IS WE ARE A LONG
WAY APART AND WE’LL SEE.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED
AN OUTCOME, IT CAN ONLY BE DONE
ON A BIPARTISAN BASIS.
WE NEED TO WORK OUR WAY THROUGH
OUR DIFFERENCES AND COME UP WITH
A SOLUTION THAT HELPS ONCE AGAIN
FOCUS WHAT I THINK WE NEED TO
APPLY THE FOCUS TO, KIDS IN
SCHOOL, HEALTH CARE, JOBS, AND
LIABILITY PROTECTIONS SO THAT
DOCTORS AND HOSPITALS, NURSES,
UNIVERSITIES, K THROUGH 12, OUR
WHOLE SOCIETY IS NOT INFLICTED
WITHIN EPIDEMIC OF LAWSUITS ON
THE HEELS OF A PANDEMIC WE ARE
ALL WRESTLING WITH.
>> Mike: CHRIS COONS WAS
CRITICAL WITH YOU FOR NOT BEING
ENGAGED IN PAST WEEKENDS
NEGOTIATIONS AND HE PREDICTS
NEGOTIATIONS WILL LEAD TO
ANOTHER $2.3 TRILLION AID
PACKAGE SIMILAR TO THE CARES
ACT.
>> IT SHOULDN’T HAVE COME TO
THIS, YOU GOT LITERALLY
30 MILLION AMERICANS WHO ARE
RELYING ON THE ADDITIONAL
UNEMPLOYMENT ASSURANCE
ASSISTANCE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO GET THEM THROUGH
THIS VERY DIFFICULT TIME.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE TO COME
TO A RESOLUTION AT THIS POINT.
>> Mike: HOW DO YOU RESPOND?
>> I AM INVOLVED, I’VE BEEN
INVOLVED CONTINUOUSLY.
THE SECRETARY OF TREASURY AND
THE PRESIDENT’S CHIEF OF STAFF
WERE BRIEFING MY COLLEAGUES ON A
DAILY BASIS, WE ARE TOTALLY
INVOLVED IN THIS.
THE QUESTION IS CAN WE WORK
TOGETHER TO GET AN OUTCOME?
THERE ARE TWO THINGS THAT ARE IN
TROUBLE AND NEED TO BE DEALT
WITH.
UNEMPLOYMENT AND THE PPP, THE
POPULAR SMALL BUSINESS LOAN
PROGRAM, BOTH EXPIRING.
WE NEED TO DO A LOT MORE THAN
THAT BUT THAT CERTAINLY CREATES
A SENSE OF URGENCY AND I HAVEN’T
SENSED THE SENSE OF URGENCY ON
THE OTHER SIDE THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO SEE TO ACTUALLY GET AN
OUTCOME.
>> Mike: HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI IS TAKING
AIM AT YOUR REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE BEING DIVIDED.
>> THEY DON’T HAVE THE VOTES --
THEY HAVE THE VOTES FOR
PRACTICALLY NOTHING, THEY
HAVEN’T PASSED ANYTHING, THEY
HAVE REFUSED TO SPEND MORE MONEY
BY AND LARGE IN THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS AND AGAIN, THAT’S A
FORMULA FOR FURTHER DISASTER.
>> Mike: TO YOUR MEMBERS
RECOGNIZED BY BEING ALL OVER THE
PLACE ON COVID RELIEF, THEY ARE
GIVING MUCH OF THE LEVERAGE TO A
LEADER SCHUMER IT SPEAKER PELOSI
SPEAKER PELOSI?
>> IN THE END, IT’S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE DONE ON A BIPARTISAN
BASIS, I’VE GOT 15 OR 20 OF MY
MEMBERS WHO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY ADDED QUITE ENOUGH TO
THE NATIONAL DEBT.
WE HAVE A DEBT NOW FOR THE SIZE
OF OUR ECONOMY FOR THE FIRST
TIME SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES IN OPINION
BUT THAT WOULDN’T GET AN
OUTCOME.
THE ONLY THING THAT GETS AN
OUTCOME IS THE SPEAKER AND THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
REACHING AN AGREEMENT.
ONCE THEY DO THAT, I BELIEVE THE
MAJORITY OF MY MEMBERS WILL
SUPPORT IT, BUT NOT EVERY SINGLE
ONE OF THEM.
I’VE BEEN CLEAR ABOUT THAT FROM
THE BEGINNING.
>> Mike: THERE’S BEEN
DISCUSSION ABOUT BRINGING RAPID
TESTING TO CAPITOL HILL AFTER
LOUIE GOHMERT TESTED POSITIVE,
HOUSE G.O.P. LEADER KEVIN
McCARTHY CALLED FOR TESTING
FOR STAFF, WHERE ARE YOU ON THIS
TESTING ISSUE?
>> BELIEVE IT OR NOT, I AGREE
WITH THE SPEAKER, WE HAVE TO
CONTINUE TO CONSULT WITH A
CAPITAL POSITION ABOUT WHAT
SHOULD BE BEST PRACTICE FOR US.
ON THE SENATE SIDE, WE’VE BEEN
WEARING MASKS AND PRACTICING
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND WE’VE BEEN
IN SESSION ALMOST CONTINUOUSLY
SINCE MAY 1ST AND WE ARE DOING
FINE.
I THINK WE ARE DEMONSTRATING
THAT YOU CAN LEARN TO LIVE WITH
THE CORONAVIRUS UNTIL WE GET THE
VACCINE, WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
LEARN TO LIVE WITH THAT, THAT
MEANS WEARING MASKS AND DOING
SOCIAL DISTANCING AND WORKING
SMARTLY IN WHICH WE COULD PUT
THIS AWFUL EXPERIENCE IN THE
REARVIEW MIRROR REARVIEW MIRROR.
>> Mike: SPORTS A HUGE PART OF
OUR CULTURE, YOU’VE GOT THE
DERBY COMING UP IN A MONTH,
YOU’VE GOT THE PROGRAMS AND
UNIVERSITY OF KENTUCKY INTO
LOUISVILLE, YOUR THOUGHT ON
SPORTS IN THE COVID ERA.
>> I’M HOPING LIKE A LOT OF
OTHER SPORTS FANS CAN WE CAN
FIGURE A WAY TO SAFELY PLAY
WEARING THIS PANDEMIC.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT FOR THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC TO GET BACK TO
NORMAL AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE.
WITH MANY OF THESE ATHLETIC
EVENTS, IT’S GOING TO BE WITH
LIMITED OR NO AUDIENCE, WE’LL
ALL BE WATCHING ON TV, AND
RETURN TO NORMAL SPORTS SAFELY
ALL ACROSS AMERICA.
>> Mike: IS IT BETTER TO HAVE
A DERBY WITH NO FANS AND AT
LEAST RUN THE RACE THAN HAVE NO
DERBY AT ALL?
>> IT’S BETTER TO HAVE A DERBY
EVEN IF THERE AREN’T ANY FANS IN
THE STANDS, WE WERE SORRY TO
HAVE TO CANCEL IT BACK IN MAY
BUT IT’S GOT TO GO OFF ON